[Musique]
au plan du fameux mur de l'atlantique
les alliés ont pratiqué déjà une large
brèche
il ya quelques jours encore les forces
alliées ne disposer que de quelques
têtes de pont aujourd'hui tout un fonds
de la forteresse européenne et aimant
play avec chaque marée favorable les
français ont vu arriver dans le cotentin
des renforts et du matériel nouveau
toujours plus puissants la bad a et des
plages et gagner également dire il y à
déjà quatre cent mille soldats alliés
sur le sol de france
l'émir essayé de résister de toutes ses
forces
l attaque a été menée à fond et bientôt
les portes de la libération
on est contact avec le peuple de france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
temps avant les allemands ne soit chassé
d'endettement extérieur des soldats
alliés sont tombés au moment même où il
démarqué
ailleurs le temps lui-même a été souvent
défavorables importants d'ouest prouver
la mer
[Musique]
dp donniez désemparé attendent leur tour
pour être emmenés vers les camps
[Musique]
l'intervention magnifique des forces
aériennes appuyant l'action des forces
terrestres a pratiquement empêcher
l'ennemi de concentrer ses rangs port
[Musique]
les avions maraudeur des routes rendez
concentration de chars dans les bois les
ont écrasés sous les bombes explosives
on les place pour dégager les alliés
débarquent air leur équipement lourd
mais caterpillar mais la priorité il
s'agissait de construire au plus vite
les pistes d'envol dans ces blocs ans et
ventre et on a trouvé beaucoup
d'allemands mort de l'un d'entre eux
avait été tué par le souffle développe
une marine survivants et des poignets
par le service de santé alliés ils
peuvent se vanter de l'avoir échappé
belle
et à pied les soldats alliés ont
progressé vers les villages et les
petites villes
[Musique]
parmi les prisonniers se trouvaient
encore quelques arrogant qui n'ont pas
compris qu'il faut lever les bras pour
autre chose que pour le salut nazi
les thoniers ont des grandes conduit en
angleterre dans les bars de débarquement
il y a quatre ans tous ces gens-là
chantait à gorge déployée
et nous irons en angleterre ils y sont
et derrière les barbelés
cependant rome est aux mains des alliés
après la brillante victoire du général
alexander général américain clark
regarde ses hommes entrant dans la
capitale italienne
les soldats alliés ont pu se rendre
compte des formidables ravages causés
aux gares de triage par les bombardiers
lourds
d'autres gardent italienne avait déjà
été détruites sans espoir de
reconstruction depuis des mois et ben si
que l'aviation bombardements alliés et
organise les voies de communication de
l'ennemi et prépare les victoires des
troupes terrestres
les armées alliées ont fait dans rome
une entrée triomphale
après vingt ans de canaillerie
mussolinienne les romains ont l'air
enchanté leurs nouveaux sorts
[Musique]
rome est la première grande capitale
européenne où les allemands ont été
chassés
[Musique]
le groupe britannique qui flotte sur
l'humeur de rome s'abolit l'occupation
de la capitale italienne par les alliés
et voilà le fameux balcon du palais de
venise où le césar de carnaval avait
coutume de hurler de te faire acclamer
par la foule
[Musique]
une boum vient d'être lancée dans
l'ancien quartier général allemand la
foule avait découvert des this link s'y
cacher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bientôt les manifestants ont défoncé les
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chefs militaires alliés pour leur
entrée dans rome près du général
américain tarp
ce trouble commandante en chef français
le général juin on les soldats ont
contribué d'une façon si décisive la
victoire taurine
les voici au balcon du capitole
et maintenant nous passons à saint
pierre de rome
500000 romains sont rassemblés devant la
colonnade du bernin
le saint père va s'adresser à la foule
[Applaudissements]
il parle bien encore la résidence de la
ville qualifiées télé loisirs sur la
famille me compare à celle historique de
mise ou mais c'est le silence
on ignore si longtemps le pape dit
rendons grâce à dieu il a épargné à rome
les horreurs de la guerre à gaza et
combinera 12 à la plus belle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
en normandie renfort des matériels
continuent d'arriver bien que les forces
alliées les plus disposer d'un grand
port le fait qu'elles s'étaient rendus
maîtresse d'une tête de pont de plus de
80 kilomètres leur permettait de
débarquer tout l'équipement d'une armée
motorisés
et l'avant s'allier rapproche les
troupes de cherbourg bien que la ville
ne peut pas encore directement menacés
les allemands ne peuvent plus dissimulée
que les alliés sont solidement établie
sur le sol de france des coûts directs
ont mis hors d'action de nombreux chars
allemands
et pendant tout ce temps bombardier les
chasseurs alliés parmi lesquels se
trouvent des galeries françaises
continuent de donner leurs puissantes
appui
partout les soldats alliés sont reçus
comme des amis par les français qui ont
conscience d'être toujours resté dans la
guerre malgré vicié l'armistice des
français font tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour aider la vente alliés
[Musique]
l'offensive n'a jamais été facile si
l'ennemi n'a pu utiliser tout de suite
c'est parce blasé il possède tout de
même plus d'un quart de millions
d'hommes dans le cotentin
quelques jours après les premiers
débarquement les alliés avaient déjà
pepy mille prisonniers dont les qualités
combattantes de la vie des vétérans de
la 8ème armées ne sauraient se comparer
à celle des soldats de romell en libye
de dures batailles devront encore être
livré mi l'armée allemande se bat depuis
plus de quatre ans elle a été
terriblement affaibli par la succession
des défaites de russie du côté allié par
contre les trompes utilisés sont des
troupes presse à bord du navire quartier
général le commandant suprême
accompagnée par l'amiral anglais rentrée
à spec de la côte
l'illustré général montgomery apporte de
bonnes nouvelles tu va repartir bientôt
pour la normandie
c'est là que quelques heures plus tard
le général de gaulle chef du
gouvernement provisoire de la république
française allait revenir en france
la france qui sous son inspiration
depuis quatre ans n'a jamais cessé de
lutter aux côtés des alliés
[Musique]